[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur Public Sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne les travaux de la
commission d'enquête sénatoriale sur le
dopage un sujet tabou mais qui fait
beaucoup parler depuis de mois les
sénateurs multiplient les auditions nous
avons l'impression que les personnes
auditionnées sautocensure a estimé le
rapporteur socialiste de cette
commission d'enquête le sénateur
Jean-Jacques lozac les sénateurs qui se
disent néanmoins confiants dans la
capacité de la commission d'enquête à
transformer ses conclusions en loi alors
sans plus tarder cette table ronde sur
les enjeux sociétaux du dopage bonne
après-midi à tous messieur
bonjour nous allons si vous le voulez
bien commencer notre
rencontre pour la première fois nous
avons souhaité une table ronde et je
vous remercie les uns et les autres
d'avoir accepté d'y participer
nous travaux vont se dérouler de la
manière
suivante nous avons souhaité avoir le
point de vue des sportifs avec Christoph
basson etan
Montour le point de vue médical avec les
professeurs et
Michel le point de vue sociologique avec
Monsieur
patri point de vue enfin avec Jean
Lafontant parce que la prévention du
dopage doit commencer selon nous dès le
plus jeune âge et être poursuivi tout au
long de de la carrière
sportive puisque nous sommes dans le
cadre d'une commission d'enquête je vais
vous demander de bien vouloir vous
prêter à un élément très simple qui est
la prestation de serment on va le faire
tous ensemble ce sera plus
simple vous devez donc prêter serment en
en disant en promettant de dire la
vérité toute la vérité sur ce sujet qui
nous occupe et en levant la main droite
en disant je le jure je vous en
prie je jure je le jure
merci nous
avons
décidé d'organiser nos travaux qui vont
durer
2h de la manière suivante chacun d'entre
vous va pouvoir s'exprimer
pendant 5 minutes pour nous dire
rapidement quelle est sa vision de ce
phénomène ce problème qui est le dopage
et puis ensuite nous ouvrirons une
discussion en vous posant un certain
nombre de
questions sur ce sujet important qui
nous préoccupe donc je
vais partir de la gauche vers la droite
en vous disant de bien vouloir voir en 5
minutes c'est pas chronométré comme une
épreuve sportive mais nous essaierons de
tenir les délais et en demandant à
Monsieur Grégory Michel d'être le
premier intervenant sur ce sujet
monsieur le professeur Vous AVEZ LA
PAROLE bien monsieur le Président
messieurs et mesdames les députés et mes
chers collègues donc je vous remercie
beaucoup de me donner la possibilité de
de donner en tout cas mon mon point vue
sur sur cette lourde question qui est le
dopage donc je remercie vraiment cette
comité cette commission d'enquête sur
l'efficacité de la lutte contre dopage
donc donc je suis Grégor Michel je suis
professeur de psychologie plus
particulièrement de psychopathologie
donc à l'université Bordeaux c'est Galen
où je dirige le laboratoire psychologie
santé et qualité de vie alors je
travaille depuis à peu près une une
bonne quinzaine d'années sur les les
comportements à risque les les conduites
de consommation notamment chez chez les
enfants et les
adolescents en milieu scolaire dans le
domaine aussi sportif au travers de de
comportement de de prise de risque et
donc j'ai été amené effectivement à à
travailler sur sur cette question des
liens entre la consommation de
substances et la pratique
sportive alors je pense que aujourd'hui
j'ai plus particulièrement axé on va
dire mon propos sur sur les aspects pour
le coup psychologiques
psychopathologiques peut-être vous me le
direz autour d'une tranche d'âge un peu
plus spécifique qui est celle des des
adolescents puisque c'est principalement
mon domaine de de compétence et j'ai été
amené donc c'était en 2010 à participer
notamment à la demande de l'Académie de
médecine à rendre un rapport sur l'état
des lieux des
connaissances sur le dopage et les
pratiques dopantes justement chez
essentiellement les les adolescents un
petit peu chez les enfants mais les
travaux sont effectivement rare à partir
d'un d'un recensement de la
littérature internationale et
nationale évidemment alors dans dans ce
ce travail éminemment on va dire
scientifique et universitaire il
s'agissait de dresser un état des lieux
des des connaissances à partir des
aspects on va dire un peu plus sensuel
des aspects un peu plus contreversés et
puis surtout d'essayer de repérer quels
étaient les les facteurs les facteurs
associés voire peut-être même les
facteur de risque voire même les
déterminants alors dans je vous donne
quelques lignes bien sûr on va
approfondir tous ces aspects j'espère
par la
suite déjà la le premier élément c'était
que
les les comportements d'pan ne sont pas
si rares que ça effectivement chez les
adolescents que ça concerne pas
uniquement les adolescents qui sont
engagés dans une pratique d'excellence
mais aussi dans une pratique un peu plus
récréative que ces conduites sont
déterminées par un certain nombre de
facteurs propres on va dire au sport à
certains types de sport basé par exemple
sur l'aspect corporel sur sur notamment
la recherche de de performance et cetera
que ça pouvait être lié à certaines
modalités de la pratique t que la l'hy
spécialisation du sport notamment de
façon un peu plus précoce et puis des
aspects qui m'ont particulièrement
préoccupé c'est des aspects plutôt
individuel psychologique propre on va
dire aux adolescents l'âge par exemple
le genre on voit que les garçons
effectivement sont plus à mêmein de
consommer ce type de de produit à peu
près deux fois plus que que les filles
même si on observe en tout cas une
augmentation sur les dernières années de
la prise de produits d'pan chez chez les
jeunes filles notamment les stéroïdes
anabolisants qui vont avoir aussi un
effet sur bah sur cette recherche de
l'esthétisme et de l'apparence corporel
et puis des
aspects propres notamment aux conduites
de consommation de façon plus large
c'est-à-dire que la prise de produit
dopan est souvent une poli consommation
hein donc il y a une coocurrence comme
ça de comportement euh de conduite de
consommation qui s'étendent bien au-delà
d'ailleurs des produits dopan reconnus
hein par par les listes c'est-à-dire
tabac alcool drogue il y a même aussi
des travaux sur sur les les suppléments
hein c'estàd qui sembl être en tout cas
pour certains une sorte de marqueur donc
en terme effectivement
de de programme par exemple de
prévention ça pourrait être
effectivement une piste intéressante à à
retenir et puis des éléments propres
effectivement au aux jeunes avec des
éléments psychologiques tels que une
faible estime de soi l'anxiété des
facteurs un peu plus émotionnels
dépressifs qui semblent effectivement
associé à ce type de de consommation euh
et puis sur l'autre versant même si on
va dire qu'il y a parfois certains
chevauchements c'està-dire des jeunes
qui sont plutôt dans une conduite un
petit peu transgressive sans doute aussi
déterminé par des attitudes et des
représentations sociales assez
spécifiques et singulières vis-à-vis des
produits dopan c'est une tendance à
légitimer et cetera donc l'objectif de
ce rapport c'était de dresser un état
des lieux des connaissances pour ensuite
aider hein juste la mise en place de de
Programm de de prévention et d'action
effectivement à la fois ciblé mais
peut-être aussi un peu plus généraliste
de manière à avoir un impact beaucoup
plus large on va dire sur sur la société
de de ces jeunes
avec un regard enfin on va en parler
aussi qui peut s'étendre bien au-delà on
va dire du du domaine sportif
c'est-à-dire cette notion de culte de la
performance et cetera ou le le socius va
être effectivement important donc je
sais que j'ai dû dépasser les 5 minutes
pas tout à fait vous alliez vous étiez
sur le point de les dépacer je me
préparais à vous arrêter merci on aura
l'occasion d'y revenir euh docteur euh
l
bonjour donc je vais préciser mon mon
action actuellement donc je suis médecin
biologist hôpitaux je dirige le
département d'hématologie clinique et
biologique du centre hospitalier 3
depuis 1992 j'ai été nommé professeur de
d'ingénierie en santé et biotechnologie
à l'École Centrale de Paris qui n'est
pas une fac de médecine mais une école
d'ingénieur en 2001 et je suis donc un
spécialiste des biotechnologies et en
particulier bien que relevant du secteur
public je suis impliqué au sens noble du
terme dans de nombreuses relations
publiqu privé du point de vue du
transfert de technologie dans le domaine
des biotechnologies appliquées à la
santé je suis consultant pour pour une
quinzaine d'entreprises biotechnologique
et
biopharmaceutique ce qui veut dire que
pour des raisons de conflit d'intérêt je
n'ai jamais voulu occuper de fonction
nationale dans le casre des
institutions publiques s'occupant de
dopage tout ça c'est bien loin du dopage
c'était bien donc j'ai en fait si j'ai
si j'ai cité ça c'est parce que 90 % de
mes relations publico-privé dans le
cadre de la République française se font
avec des entreprises nord-américaines et
que le discloser Act aux États-Unis
existe depuis 25 ans bien avant que la
transparence et touché notre
pays donc c'est un peu loin du dopage en
fait si je suis confronté au dopage
c'est parce que je viens moi-même du
sport j'ai arrêté de jou rugby en
1986 je suis détenteur des diplômes
d'entraîurs nationaux qui me
permettraiit d'entraîner un club
professionnel du
rugby aujourd'hui et en 1980 5 JAC forou
2 ans avant la première coupe du monde
de rugby m'a demandé de rentrer dans le
staff pour l'aider à passer du cassoulet
busé à la préparation rationnelle de ce
sport folklorique qui était à l'époque
le rugby français dans la cadre de la
mondialisation liée à la première coupe
du monde de rugby dans ce contexte j'ai
donc assumé le rôle de
programmeur puisque je vais pas vous
raconter comment on se préparait dans le
rugby avant
1985 la deuxee place cette première
coupe du monde de rugby a laissé penser
que la méthode que nous avions appliqué
méritait d'être
suivie grâce à ma position nous avons
donc travaillé sur l'introduction de la
biologie dans le sport de haut niveau ce
qui était facile dans le rugby puisquil
y avait rien et donc nous avons notre
équipe a été à la base du concept de
suivi biologique longitudinale à partir
de
1985 et en 19 95 le cabinet Drut puis le
cabinet buffet en relation avec Alain
Garnier qui a été cité tout à l'heure et
qui occupe d'autres fonctions a souhaité
utiliser nos moyens biologiques
indirect pour mettre en place le
passeport biologique sportif que nous
avons formalisé en 1998
entre 1998 et 2002 comme vous le savez
il y a un séisme terrible qui
aujourd'hui trouve un épilogue curieux
ce passeport biologique sportif que nous
avions développé pour la France et le
Ministère Français n'a pas été appliqué
sur le Tour de France ce qui a permis à
une personnalité connue aujourd'hui dans
le monde de pouvoir gagner se Tours de
France on nous a interdit d'utiliser ce
passeport biologique de la recherche
publique française que nous avions conçu
dans le casre d'une mission de recherche
publique en raison de mon impossibilité
d'occuper des fonctions officielles vu
les engagements très importants qui sont
les miens dans le domaine industriel
avec malheureusement je le regrette très
peu d'entreprises françaises depuis 15
ans je joue un rôle d'expert national et
international auprès de très nombreuses
fédérations pour utiliser la biologie
préventive pour comprendre ce qui se
passe dans le dopage et prévenir les
choses tout à l'heure à l'audition
d'avant une partie de ces travaux ont
été
cités je suis donc expert auprès d'un
certain nombre d'organisations
internationales sportives sans fonction
officielle
et dans le cadre de demande ponctuelle
de la part d'autorités de mon pays ou
d'autorité
internationale je joue un rôle d'expert
vis-à-vis de deux dossiers qui touchent
au dopage élargis à partir du sport de
haut niveau c'est-à-dire le mésusage
médicamenteux qui a été évoqué par mon
collègue et qui est aujourd'hui une
réalité c'est-à-dire que beaucoup de
médicaments sont détournés y compris des
médicaments non considérés comme dopan
mais qu'ils sont dopan quand ils sont
mal utilisés et deuxièmement une
criminalité internationale très
importante qui est la contrefaçon
médicamenteuse par rapport aujourd'hui à
énormément de médicaments notamment les
médicaments biotch qui ont un malheur
c'est qu'ils coûtent très cher et qu'ils
sont donc très rapidement une partie de
ces produits sont des produits
potentiellement dopant et je vais
m'arrêter là merci pour ces propos
liminires monsieur Christophe
basson bonjour donc déjà merci pour pour
ce travail parce c'est vrai que ça on
patiente on patiente il y a des affaires
qui date maintenant depuis 15 ans et et
on a encore du mal à rester motivé donc
c'est c'est c'est vraiment bon plaisant
et motivant de de pouvoir de pouvoir
continuer à travailler là dessus avec
vous euh moi moi je vais pas du tout
revenir sur ma carrière je ve dire sur
sur mon expérience de sportif je pense
que on pourra y revenir après si si vous
le souhaitez mais mais j'aurais préféré
aborder le le problème d'une manière
différente en fait j'ai d'abord reçu une
convocation pour les G les enjeux
sociétaux des pratiques dopante et au
final je me retrouve aux enjeux
sociétaux du dopage alors déjà là il y a
déjà une petite distinction qui est
peut-être volontaire mais je pense qu'on
pourra on pourrait y revenir tout ça
pour dire qu'en fait le problème les en
sociét du dopage ne sont pas que ceux du
dopage en fait je crois que c'est le
sport en général parce qu'on on se
retrouve actuellement dans une situation
où où on veut de la performance mais en
comprepartie on veut lutter contre le
dopage et et depuis des années on se
rend compte que finalement l'un et
l'autre ne vont pas ensemble il arrive
un moment où où où il va il va peut-être
falloir faire un choix je crois que
justement je crois que c'est dans le
cadre du de la réforme du de de de la
loi cadre sur le sport et pas sur le
dopage et je pense c'est peut-être pour
ça qu'il faudra éventuellement élargir
la réflexion là-dessus parce que parce
que le le le dopage au
fond je vois pas comment on va pouir
devenir de plus en plus efficace si on
en demande toujours autant au sportif et
si on recherche autant la performance
quand je dis performance c'est globale
tel qu'elle est à la première définition
que l'on peut trouver et non pas par la
petite définition qui est la performance
individuelle je crois que là-dessus on
est sur de la comparaison et on on va
droite au mur si on continue comme ça
c'est tout donc ça c'est juste
l'introduction là-dessus pourquoi tout
ça parce que pour moi le dopage est une
solution à plusieurs problèmes il y a
plusieurs problèmes à différents niveaux
le premier niveau déjà c'est l'individu
l'individu va trouver des solutions à
son problème le problème il peut être
diverse problème ça va être un problème
d'argent un problème de reconnaissance
un problème de bien-être parce que faut
pas oublier on parle souvent de santé
depuis 15 ans on parle de santé physique
quand on parle de santé mais la santé
c'est le bien-être physique mental et
social et je crois que le côté mental et
social faut pas l'oublier et souvent
pour un sportif finalement le dopage lui
permet un bien-être social et ensuite un
bien-être mental et même et même après
est-ce que ça enlève réellement le
bien-être physique c'est la question que
l'on doit se poser parce que on fait de
la prévention depuis des années en
disant que le dopage dangereux pour la
santé on le dit oui on le dit mais je je
peux vous garantir que les sportifs n'en
sont pas persuadés c'est vrai que
maintenant des nouveaux produits
arrivent comme le GW 15 16 et cetera où
où on affirme que c'est hyper dangereux
mais en attendant on a pas d'exemple
tant mieux hein je dirais qu'on est pas
d'exemple mais malheureusement on n'est
pas efficace là-dessus donc pourquoi en
fait on lutte contre le dopage si on
fait le tour de tout alors ça c'est que
le côté individuel après il y a le côté
général pourquoi il y a du dopage parce
que c'est une solution aussi au côté je
dirais politique économique dans le sens
où on veut quoi bien on veut un pays qui
soit au niveau des autres pays ou en
avance par rapport aux autres pays sur
le niveau sportif qu' a des résultats
qui soi dans un bon classement au niveau
international ensuite on veut quoi les
fédérations doivent exister les
fédérations qu'est-ce qui se passe
fédération ben elles sont valorisé on
parlait de convention d'objectif tout à
l'heure mais elles sont valorisé sur
quoi sur nombre de licenciés sur les
résultats internationaux et et et donc
au final on se dit finalement pourquoi
on lutte contre le dopage parce qu'on
retrouve en fait l'éthique je crois que
c'est l'éthique qui est importante c'est
c'est le respect c'est c'est c'est c'est
c'est la dignité en fait c'est défendre
le respect et je crois être capable de
se regarder dans une glace je crois que
c'est la première des choses et je crois
que si je suis là encore aujourd'hui je
crois et si je continue à me battre pour
ça c'est parce que je souhaiteraai que
justement tous ces jeunes qui arrivent
ils continuent à pouvoir se regarder
dans une glace et ils soit fier de le
faire il sont fier de le faire alors
aussi bien on peut être fier en se
regardant dans une glace en ayant fait
une erreur au préalable même deux
erreurs mais la question c'est surtout
les assumer et quand moi aujourd'hui je
vois arriver des tricheurs qui
reviennent après 2 ans de suspension 3
ans de suspension avec le grand sourire
je crois que le problème il est là même
on a beau comme j'entendais tout à
l'heure leur faire payer une amende de
50000 € si au fond de lui la personne si
au fond d'elle la personne n'est pas
touchée parce qu'elle a triché je crois
qu'on a loupé quelque chose mais c'est
quelque chose on les a loupé 15 ans
avant 20 ans avant lors de son éducation
et et dernièrement j'ai discuté avec un
collègue qui partait à la retraite parce
que je suis prof de sport dans une
direction régionale et je mets en place
maintenant les contrôs entilopage dans
la région aquitain et je discutais avec
lui qui était formé à l'ancienne école
PS et il m' m'a sorti un petit livre des
tables de mesures pour évaluer les
élèves et je lis et et je lis la préface
et qu'est-ce que je lis à l'intérieur
que final le P c'est quoi c'est
atteindre les sommets mais pas les
sommets de manière générale mais les
sommets de l'athlète et à partir du
moment où on entre excusez-moi à partir
du moment où le gamin entre dans un
milieu sportif je critique pas le milieu
sportif il est fait comme ça et on l'a
construit comme ça on le pousse vers la
performance performance comme je vous
disais globale que moi j'intitule la
réussite et on se retrouve dans un
système de compétition je suis pas
contre la compétition comme disait
Albert jacard je crois que c'est c'est
un moyen d'émulation la compétition i
mais mais mais il faut il faut revoir
tout ça et justement au niveau des
solutions il y en a je crois qu'on y
reviendra tout à l'heure mais déjà sur
la qualification des éducateur des
choses comme ça on doit conserver
l'éducation plutôt que de passer soit
dans l'entraînement ou la gestion d'une
animation et mais bon je pense qu'on y
reviendra tout à l'heure on y reviendra
merci pour cette introduction à nos
débats monsieur herwan monour bonjour
écoutez moi je suis je suis content
d'être parmi vous mais je suis un petit
peu plus
un petit peu plus mesuré partagé j'ai le
sentiment que s'attaquer au dopage c'est
un petit peu s'attaquer à la nature de
l'homme déjà pour
commencer Christophe qui est à côté de
moi peut faire figure de héros de ma
génération puisque moi je suis rentré
dans une dans un milieu professionnel
dans le cyclisme très jeune
contrairement à lui moi dès que j'avais
15 ans je savais que j'allais me Doer
j'avais vu mon frère le faire avant moi
c'était ça faisait que ça n'était que
satisfaire une ex de ce métier
euh je crois que c'est vraiment
consubstantiel à l'homme le dopage dire
dans tout les compartiments de la
société on retrouve le dopage
aujourd'hui ce que je trouve triste
c'est que on affiche une volonté
politique on est là d'ailleurs pour ça
de lutter contre le dopage mais on on y
lutte de manière totalement parcellaire
parce que si on voulait vraiment trouver
le dopage on le trouverait on le trouve
aujourd'hui principalement dans le vélo
on s'attaque pas aux autres disciplines
je suis très content que que tu abordes
c'est ces questions philosophiques et et
que tu intellectualise toute la démarche
mais soit on essaie de faire quelque
chose soit on le fait pas c'est
évidemment une question d'éducation moi
j'ai été élevé dans la
compétition si on si on prend un peu de
recul qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
cette cette proposition de société qu'on
fait à un enfant quand on lui propose de
faire du sport c'est les meilleurs
devant les mauvais
derrière forcément quelqu'un qui est
mauvais s'il doit être confronté à ce
milieu et ben il va avoir envie de
progresser et il va progresser comment
il va se doppper dans tous les autres
compartiments de la société on va
valoriser ça quelqu'un qui trouve des
solutions pour progresser mais pas dans
le sport les sportifs ils sont pas à
Disneyland ils sont confrontés à une une
pression beaucoup plus importante la
compétition induit forcément la triche
voilà c'est mon point de
vue merci Monsieur Jean Lafontan
responsable du syndicat national des
éducateurs je représente plutôt les
professeurs d'éducation physique pas les
éducateurs pour lesquels je n'ai aucune
compétence particulière donc
écoutez nous sommes excusez-moi non il a
pas de problème euh moi il me semble que
nous sommes en tant qu'enseignant
confronté à une question un peu
redoutable entre l'injonction morale sur
la façon dont on perçoit le le dopage ce
qu'il faudrait faire parce que on voit
bien que tout le regard se tourne vers
l'éducation de la prime enfance jquà
l'âge adulte et finalement
euh nous n'avons pas cette réalité en
face de nous je le dis comme ça il faut
savoir queéducation physique si le
dopage c'est la confrontation aux
limites de l'homme avec 2 heures
d'éducation physique à lycée les
adolescents sont loin de leur limite je
dirais peut-être que les 6e qui ont 4
heur et qui sont j'en ai eu inépuisable
on pourrait doubler l'horaire dans la
semaine ça leur ferait aucun problème je
dirais des Adol ça quand on parle de ça
c'est toujours au détour je dirais de
débat ou de l'actualité mais on peut pas
parler d'intervention systématique des
enseignants parce que on parle quelque
chose qui leait est totalement abstrait
on narrive même pas à faire le minimal
dans chez les adolescents avec 2 heures
par semaine lorsquon sait que 2 heur
c'est même pas les heures effectives on
pourrait presque diviser par
de voilà donc j'avais toujours dit
lorsque j'étais convoqué à cette réunion
que on m'a menené à parler d'un problème
d'abord qui fait que le dopage pour moi
c'est un problème qui est d'abord social
ça se finit pas par la physiologie ou la
médecine c'est je crois que ce qu'a dit
basson c'est parfaitement juste vous
savez l'éducation physique on a dans No
programme au moins une définition une
finalité qui fait accord on dit former
un citoyen cultivé lucide autonome
physiquement et socialement éduqué c'est
généreux et heureusement que l'éducation
a les grands élans de générosité sinon
on aurait une jeunesse être en perdition
donc voilà ensuite le milieu des
anciensnes éducationsiques est un milieu
qui est individuellement qui peut être
très sportif mais qui du point de vue de
sa fonction à beaucoup de distance avec
le sport et nous avons même une approche
très critique du sport je crois que
c'est un des premiers éléments de
l'approche du sport de le faire
comprendre les élèves et notamment vous
savez dans les cours éducation il y a
pas beaucoup de compétition la
compétition la retrouve beaucoup dans le
sport scolaire et là effectivement nous
avons alors dans le sport scolaire je me
suis renseigné ici il y a une lutte
contre le dopage alors vous savez il y a
12 contrôles bon c'est microscopique
pour l'instant sur les années 2007-21 il
y avait pas de cas positifs mais enfin
je veux dire la compétition scolaire
l'uncs c'est quand c'est les phases
nationales et internationales où les
jeunes sont vraiment confrontés à de
vraies questions de compétition dans les
niveaux euh de district ou département
nous ne sommes pas là donc nous avons je
crois une question à mon avis qui est
assez euh on la trouve chez nous par
exemple on nous avons dans les lycées de
l'enseignement d'exploration 5 heur par
semaine en plus des sur d'éducation
physique pour une minorité d'élèves 3000
élèves
ouz 3000 élèves il y a quand même
2200000 lycéens donc c'est quand même
c'est pas une élite c'est des jeunes que
l'on prend parce que ils sont intéressés
par la pratique sportive donc ça fait
quand même et nous avons aussi une
option
facultative là il y a dans ces options
là des thèmes d'étude dans lequel le
dopage est
abordé c'est le seul moment nous avons
des sections sportives scolaires dans
les collèges il y a une quarantaine de
1000 élèves 44000 mais ce ce sont à mon
avis cette question elle vient je dirais
au détour de débat la compétition et
l'entraînement que subissent les goss
dans les sections sportives scolaires ce
n'est pas quand même celle que
connaissent nos amis cyclistes au niveau
ils ont pratiqué voilà donc je crois que
on a pour l'éducation physique ça serait
pas être heureux de multiplier les
horaires et je pense à mon avis que
cette question du doopas c'est une
question qu'il faut surtout ne pas
médicaliser c'est le système qui crée le
dopage et je veux dire il faut pas trop
la moraliser parce que vous savez on vit
dans une époque où quand même la morale
c'est fait être que pour les pauvres
donc nous sommes très attentifs à ces
questions là de ne pas surcharger la
responsabilité des enseignants qui
vivent dans une époque où ces questions
là ne rencontreraient pas sur ce qu'ils
disent ce que les gosses vivent dans
leur propre vie
sociale je crois qu'il y a il faut être
attentif à ces questions l'éducation on
subit d'énormes pressions actuellement
de
transformation il va y avoir
l'enseignement moral et civique je c'est
parce que ça va être de Monsieur payon
donc j'ai rien trouvé de développé sur
cette question moi je crois que n en
vient aux questions de morale lorsque la
la société ne sait plus se réguler et
mettre en place des des bornes un peu
qui serait à ne pas dépasser et qui
ferait consensus dans la société on a
recours à ces moments-là lorsque plus
rien n'a éclaté la crise morale est une
crise sociale c'est un peu comme ça
qu'on que les collègues le vivent et
certainement parl avec leurs élèves
quand ils sont confrontés à ces
questions voilà je vous remercie merci à
vous Monsieur Patrick Lure docteur on
vous
écoute vous remercie de m'avoir convié à
cette commission
d'enquête alors je suis un peu surpris
parce
que ma ma triple formation ne me rend
pas compétent dans aucun deschang je
suis médecin effectivement médecin de
santé publique euh je suis docteur en
sciences et j'ai également une formation
en sociologie j'exerce toujours à
l'heure actuelle comme médecin
conseiller à la Direction Régionale de
la Jeunesse des Sports et de la Cohésion
Sociale de laoren également comme
chercheur associé au laboratoire de
sociologie de l'Université de laorine
c'est vous dire que je suis très mauvais
à la fois comme médecin n'exerçant pas
comme sociologue n'exerçant pas et euh
comme docteur en physique n'exerçant pas
non plus voilà euh cela dit cela dit je
vais quand même tenter de faire semblant
d'être compétent dans le domaine
concerné puisque j'ai eu le privilège et
l'honneur d'y mener un certain nombre de
travaux en particulier auprès du jeune
public et du jeune public sportif
notamment voilà euh en effet les
quelques travaux que j'ai pu mener dont
j'ai reconnu un certain nombre de de
références par Grégory Michel ont
soulevé des questions épidémiologiques à
savoir
à l'époque et c'était un peu
révolutionnaire est-ce que les jeunes
sportifs se dopent ou pas alors c'est
une question que à la fin des années 90
on ne se posait pas
encore et puis surtout au-delà de cette
question de l'épidémiologie de la
prévalence de l'incidence de la nature
des produits du coût que ça engendre
pour les jeunes de leur perception de la
santé et des risques qu'ils encourent
mon idée était d'appliquer ensuite
toutes ces connaissances à la prévention
du dopage des qu' du dopand chez les
jeunes bien bien entendu voilà euh la
plupart de ces travaux ont été publiés
au plan national ou international
également sous forme
d'ouvrage très disparat dans leur thème
puisque certains concernent
effectivement la société comme ça a été
souligné dopage et société par exemple
d'autres concernent la biologie ou la
physiologie notamment l'exploration
biologique du sportif que nous avions
commis ensemble avec gérardine à
l'époque où c'était quelque chose
d'assez révolutionnaire là
encore alors
tout cela pour dire que au fond le
dopage sportif pour moi ne représente
qu'une conduite dopante parmi d'autres
conduite d'upante je suis l'heureux papa
de ce de ce concept en
1995 conduite d'opand c'est une conduite
de consommation de substance pour être
performant quelle que soit la nature de
la substance soit-elle interdite ou pas
et quelle que soit surtout la nature de
la performance elle peut-être sportive
ou pas bien entendu professionnelle
académique ou quotidienne peut nous
importe l'idée générale était de pouvoir
étendre la notion de dopage à ce que
l'on observe en général dans la vie
quotidienne et ce qui a été fort bien
décrit par Monsieur Michel et etedine
tout à l'heure dès lors ça nous
fournissait ça nous permettait de de
nous extraire un peu du climat
idéologique qui régnait autour du dopage
à la fin des années 90 pour ramener le
dopage comme un objet scientifique parmi
d'autres et du coup pouvoir se poser des
questions scientifiques pour pouvoir
l'étudier c'était ça l'objet et du coup
au-delà de ces
travaux j'ai pu conforter renforcer un
un modèle
explicatif qui essaie de prendre en
compte l'ensemble des valeurs mais qui
n'y parvient pas bien sûr comme tous les
modèles théoriques à savoir que lation
de conduite dopante et de dopage sportif
puisque le doppage sportif est une
conduite dopand particulière résulte de
la rencontre et de l'interaction entre
trois éléments la personne ici le
sportif en l'occurrence qui va se
caractériser par son sexe son âge et
cetera la substance bien sûr qui va se
caractériser elle aussi par sa nature sa
dangerosité son accessibilité et ainsi
de suite et bien sûr l'environnement
dans lequel tout cela se passe à savoir
la notion de performance de contrainte
de recherche de culte de la performance
mais également le contexte politique
religieux culturel tradition du recours
ou pas à une substance pour être
performant et quand je dis performant
n'entendez pas dans mon propos réussite
sportive à tout prix performance de haut
niveau entendez simplement performance
telle qu'on peut la concevoir au
quotidien être ici par exemple à
supposer que j'ai énormément de
difficultés à prendre la parole en
public et bien ce serait pour moi une
performance du quotidien d'être parmi
vous alors en quelques
mots nous avons réussi à montrer tant
tant au plan national que régional dans
certaines régions que parmi les jeunes
sportifs qui encore une fois le public
adolescent estant celui que je connais
le
mieux en gros quand on les
interroge 3 à 5 % d'entre eux disent oui
j'ai déjà consommé une substance
interdite au cours des 6 derniers
mois quelle que soit la nature de la
substance interdite hein elle figure sur
la liste ce qui nous intéresse
ici on a pu isoler les différents
déterminants qui ont été écrit par
Monsieur Michel tout à l'heure donc je
n'y reviens pas c'est le sexe c'est
l'âge et cetera et également pour ce qui
est du sportif de tous les jours du
sportif amateur on a pu montrer cette
importance de l'estime de soi de de la
relation entre une faible estime de soi
une anxiété peut-être plus importante
bref des gamins qui sont un peu en
mal-être et qui du coup effectivement
comme disait Christophe basson tout à
l'heure vont trouver peut-être dans
l'usage de substances à des fans
performan une solution
à leur mal-être ou du moins le croi-il
mais ça peut être également pour
d'autres enjeux par exemple intégrer un
groupe de pères pair qui consomme déjà
des substances et dont il voudrait faire
partie et donc il s'approprient leur rit
et ça devient un rit initiatique en
quelque sorte mais c'est ce que l'on
observe également dans le sport de haut
niveau c'est un autre sujet pour
terminer j'en reviens à la notion de
l'efficacité de la l antidopage qui est
le thème de cette commission d'enquête
et qui me pose un certain souci
euh si on se réfère non pas la
commission bien entendu que je trouve
particulièrement légitime et et dont je
salue
l'action mais la question elle-même en
effet si on se réfère à un certain
nombre de de vrais sociologues à travers
par exemple la théorie des jeux ou le
fait social de d'Émil Durkheim et bien
on ne peut que craindre que la notion de
dopage soit au-delà de l'homme ou de la
femme et dès lors que on ne pourra
guerre faire quoi que ce soit pour
l'éradiquer enre totalité cela dit cela
ne veut pas dire qu'il faut baisser les
bras bien au contraire et si on décrit
maintenant un certain nombre d'objectifs
sur la lutte antidopage thème de la
Commission et bien on est là aussi un
peu surpris que il n'y ait pas
d'évaluation jusqu'à présent par exemple
si on pose la
question comme on me la pose parfois
est-ce que les contrôles antidopages
permettent de diminuer le recours au
substance chez les sportifs et bien je
ne suis pas en mesure de répondre à
cette question puisque à ma connaissance
en tout
cas ça n'a pas été évalué jusqu'à
présent scientifiquement en revanche
dans le champ qui est le mien à savoir
la prévention si on me pose la question
existe-t-il des actions de prévention
des conduites de pente qui permettent de
réduire cet usage chez les jeunes en
particulier les les jeunes sportifs je
répond oui bien entendu et ça a été
publié
merci
je me retourne vers le rapporteur
êtes-vous prêt cher
ami on y va quelques premières questions
pour lancer le premier tour de table
tout en sachant que vous pouvez
également vous interpeller
réciproquementation seulement dans le
dans le débat dans le débat qui qui va
suivre ou une première question à à
Monsieur Michel puisque donc vous avez
étudié la la nature
des conduites addictives et je voudais
savoir si effectivement dans ces
conduites addictives là il y a une
spécificité dans l'usage des produits
dopan ou bien est-ce qu'on retrouve
exactement toutes les caractéristiques
de n'importe quelle conduite de
dépendance voulez dire
spécificité en
terme de personnalité en terme
d'engagement en terme de
motivation alors c'est c'est un peu
compliqué et du coup Patrick l va aussi
sans doute apporter sa contribution à
cette à cette réponse mais
euh ce que l'on sait c'est que c'est
qu'il y a en tout cas sur le plan on va
dire des caractéristiques individuelles
et et du coup on a eu un échange là
autour de la notion de d'anxiété
d'estime de soi et cetera c'est que
c'est ces caractéristiques comme ça qui
répondent à une sorte de fragilité comme
ça de l'adolescent c'est une fragilité
que l'on retrouve on va dire dans
l'ensemble des conduites de consommation
chez l'adolescent c'est-à-dire comme
effectivement ça été dit c'est-à-dire
une sorte de recours momentané à une
fragilité intérieure c'est-à-dire une
fragilité qui se situe donc en amont
souvent hein de la confrontation d'un
produit qui va momentanément résoudre
une tension
intérieure qui peut être lié justement à
une une insatisfaction corporelle par
exemple on sait qu'il effectivement des
des adolescents qui vont prendre
certains produits parce que ça va leur
permettre de de se sentir mieux dans
leur corps de se sentir mieux aussi
vis-à-vis des autres des adolescents
vis-à-vis aussi de l'adulte hein
vis-à-vis d'une performance qui peut
être aussi très subjective comme ça a
été mentionné c'est-à-dire c'est pas
simplement une une performance à
l'extrême c'est une performance
effectivement au quotidien donc là on
est dans quelque chose d'assz d'assez
généraliste on va dire l'autre aspect
qui est aussi généraliste comme je
disais
c'est c'est c'est un peu une question
comme ça a été évoqué un peu de presque
de citoyenneté c'est-à-dire le fait de
prendre des produits qui sont reconnus
comme étant effectivement interdits qui
sont aussi néfastes effectivement pour
la santé donc prendre des produits qui
sont néfastes pour la santé alors qu'ils
ont besoin de prendre ces produit pour
justement se sentir mieux donc ça c'est
effectivement des éléments que l'on que
l'on retrouve avec des tendances
justement de l'ordre de de la c'est
évoqué un peu de la tricherie de la
transgression et cetera donc moi en tout
cas dans l'expérience que j'ai au-delà
on va dire de de programme de prévention
qui seraiit du coup plus élictif ou
spécifique on va dire à la prévention
des des comportements ou des conduite
depente c'est c'est des programmes
presque un peu plus généralistes
c'est-à-dire que ces problèmes de de
consommation chez les chez les sportifs
de haut niveau mais chez aussi les
sportifs qui sont plus dans une logique
un peu plus récréative et où on va
retrouver aussi cette notion un peu de
performance presque au
quotidien c'est de de pouvoir en tout
cas questionner ces ces programmes de
prévention un de façon un peu plus
précoce c'est-à-dire que là on répond on
va dire à des déterminants qui sont un
peu plus presque éducatif donc donc on
est dans des programmes qui sont qui
s'inscrivent dans la durée c'estàd qu'on
sait très bien que les programmes qui
sont juste des one shot qui sont juste
une seule fois des journées
d'information et cetera ça marche pas et
c'est ça peut être même parfois même
contreproductif là c'est s'inscrire
effectivement dans la durée prendre en
considération du coup certains
déterminants qui sont psychologiques
mais aussi bien d'autres dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure sur lesquell on pourrait
rejoindre reprendre mais c'est des
programmes un peu plus généralistes
parce que ces conduites comme ça
dopantes ça fait partie en tout cas pour
moi de conduit de prise de risque ou de
conduitite à risque pour la santé dans
lesquelles on va inclure l'ensemble des
conduites de consommation mais aussi des
conduites qui peuvent être effectivement
délétaires pour la santé et ça c'est
effectivement quelque chose que qui
s'apprend et qui s'inscrit dans la durée
donc ça c'est des c'est des programmes
c'est des actions qui doivent faire
intervenir on va dire différents acteurs
qui participent on va dire au
développement de l'enfant c'est des des
acteurs sur le plan sportif sur le plan
éducatif on est dans des programmes qui
sont longitudinaux et beaucoup plus
écologiques merci il y a-t-il parmi
vous telle ou telle demande
d'intervention sur le même sujet la
réponse à la même
question Monsieur
L Monsieur Michel en sachant que au-delà
de la notion de programme qui s'inscrit
dans la durée effectivement où on doit
inscrit dans le casadre de l'éducation
nationale ou du mouvement sportif des
programmes qui vont aborder
régulièrement la notion de conduite d'
pente dans des programmes autour de la
santé ou des conduites de risque plus
généraux bien entendu
mais nous sommes confrontés dans le
mouvement sportif spécifiquement à une
contrainte c'est que lorsque l'on va par
exemple dans un club de football faire
de la prévention du dopage et que l'on
dit aux jeunes devant nous écoutez
aujourd'hui vous ne ferez pas 2 heur de
foot vous nous écouterez pendant 2
heures vous parlez de dopage il
n'apprécie pas du tout du coup les
entraîneurs non plus les parents non
plus et à juste titre du reste ce qui
rend les action dans le temps dans le
cadre du mouvement sportif dans le cadre
du club extrêmement difficile à mener
Christophe
basson oui pour pour parler un peu de la
prévention juste pour information quand
Mme bon j'ai j'ai c'est pas énorme pour
par rapport à certains mais j'ai eu 15
années de licence et pendant 15 ans je
n'ai jamais eu alors à subir ou à
écouter d'action de prévention du dopage
donc ça c'est une chose à noter et j'ai
tout fait quasiment un cyclisme don je
crois que justement tout à l'heure vous
vous travaillez justement avec la
Fédération deathlétisme je crois que
vous avez parlé d'E tion objectif qu'il
y avait le ministère dans le code du
sport est mentionné que chaque
fédération doivent faire des actions de
prévention auprès de tous leurs
licenciers al je pose la question
pourquoi moi je n'ai jamais eu d'action
de prévention près de moi pendant 15 ans
je crois que là-dessus il y a quelque
chose à faire je pense et et et c'est ça
reste quand même du devoir des
fédérations alors après en terme de de
prévention auprès des jeunes on se pose
la question c'est vrai que au final
souvent on a tendance à critiquer les
sportifs de s doper et de leur jeter la
pierre mais je crois que les sportifs au
final
je suis pas du gen à dire qu'ils sont
victimes mais ils font un choix mais ils
font le choix avec les capacités qu'ils
ont et et quand pendant 15 ans vous avez
été éduqué à dire non à dire oui à dire
oui à tout parce qu'au final il faut le
voir clairement la scolarité qu'est-ce
que c'est l'enfant souvent ça a évolué
c'est vrai ces dernières années mais
l'enfant il va à l'école il dit où il y
a tout quasiment et puis à 15 ans on
demande au jeunes qui fassent un groupe
qui face un groupe qui veut intégrer
parce qu'ils se sent seul face un club
où il y a ses idoles à l'intérieur on
lui demande de refuser tout ça de dire
non alors qu'il en est incapable de dire
non mais tu l'as fait oui mais je je
l'ai fait pourquoi pourquoi finalement
je l'ai fait parce que parce qu'au final
j'ai vécu dans du coton j'ai vécu dans
du coton j'ai pas manqué l'amour de mes
parents j'ai pas eu de de manque sur le
plan financier j'ai j'ai j'ai eu une vie
privée exceptionnelle je continue à
laavir j'ai pas eu ce besoin de
reconnaissance des pères j'ai pas eu ce
besoin de reconnaissance des autres et
au final je crois que vous savez pour
avoir rencontré plusieurs psychologues
pour avoir cherch à comprendre pourquoi
moi parmi les 28 je me suis pas dopé ben
rare on réçu il y a des multiples
raisons et c'est dernièrement ma
rencontre avec bon certains le
connaissent peut-être Christophe Andray
psychiatre à Paris qui travaille
beaucoup sur estime de soi et et la
méditation de pleine conscience et et et
la simple raison elle est là c'est avoir
une bonne estime de soi c'est surtout
pas avoir une haute ni une basse mais
c'est être capable de s'apprécier
soi-même par ses résultats et pas par
comparaison par rapport aux autres et je
crois qu'il y a un gros travail à faire
là-dessus après c'est sûr à côté il y a
le côté lutte parce qu'il faut pas
oublier que la lutte contre dopage on
parle de moyens est-ce qu'il faut plus
de moyens est-ce qu'il en faut pas quand
on lutte contre le dopage au niveau des
élites on lutte contre les personnes qui
n'ont pas envie de changer et je crois
que je crois que là-dessus il faut
peut-être privilégier la toxicomanie où
là on Essie de sortir des gens de la
difficulté et ils ont envie d'en sortir
par contre la prévention il faut la
réserver auprès des jeunes et la
répression c'est clair là-dessus il faut
être intransigent au niveau des
élites ouais moi quand j'entendais
parler tout à l'heure de vulnérabilité
et de de prévention je suis extrêmement
sceptique quant à l'idée de prévention
parce que la seule chose qu'on pourrait
vraiment faire si on voulait faire
quelque chose faudrait aller dans les
familles et apprendre aux parents à
éduquer leurs
enfants c'est impossible et cette
vulnérabilité c'est le schéma familial
c'est comment on s'est construit et là
on vient de le toucher du doigt avec
Christophe qui a été capable de faire
quelque chose dans ma génération c'est
le seul le seul avec Gill de Lyon des
mecs qui ont été est capable d'être dans
un système et de dire non moi je peux
vous dire qu'à 20 ans j'étais au courant
de ce que c'était que le dopage on
m'aurait dit de boire un litre de gasoil
pour gagner le Tour de France j'en
aurais bu deux ou trois pour en gagner
plusieurs l'histoire de de de sa limite
de la mort d'avoir d'avoir des des
maladies graves à 20 ans on en a rien
àirer comment on en arrive là ben
peut-être parce que on manque d'amour on
a une relation déséquilibrée avec son
père avec sa mère et et ceux qui ont ces
problèmes là à moins d'avoir un PS à
plein temps qui vient pendant des années
s'occuper d'eux pour qu'ils aillent à la
résilience je crois que ça va être
compliqué en revanche vous voulez lutter
contre le dopage faites en sorte de
faire des contrôles qui
marchent et là le dopage va disparaître
parce qu'ils auront peur de la sanction
je crois très peu à la prévention pour
le dopage en tout
cas oui sur ce point très précis des des
contrôles parce que bon c'est ce qui se
passe notamment dans les ce qui se passe
oui ce qui se passait en tout cas vous
l'avez décrit vous l'avez écrit sur les
critériums d'aprèstour est-ce que ces
épreuves là sont toujours exonéré de
contrôle non il y a des contrôles
maintenant si vous voulez il y a si vous
regardez le nombre de contrôles qu'il y
a dans le vélo c'est c'est ahurissant il
y a même des coureurs qui arrivent à
être suspendu sans s'être
dopé c'est quand même l'année dernière
on a le cas de johanredo qui a fait
trois noch et il est il est suspendu 1
an alors qu'il y a des mecs dans
d'autres pays qui sont contrôlés positif
et qui vont être suspendu 3 mois donc si
vous voulez il y a il y a une
telle une telle disparité dans les
contrôles tant dans une même discipline
au niveau international parce qu'en
France il va y avoir des moyens d'autres
en Espagne d'autres en Italie et à côté
de ça dans des sports comme le foot ou
le tennis où il y a pas de contrôle donc
si vous voulez c'est il y a que si on
légifère au niveau mondial au niveau du
dopage dans tous les sports qu'on pourra
faire quelque chose
oui donc comme je vous disais charger
des contre antidopage sur radiakitain
oui les les je crois que les les les
critériums tout ça on les contrôle on
essaie d'être le plus proche du terrain
possible parce que vous avez entendu des
gens de la FLD euh je crois qu'il faut
pas oublier qu'il a ces gens de terrain
agent de l'État qui travaillent
là-dessus je crois que sans ces
agents-là on naurait pas justement les
informations qui peuvent nous remonter
du terrain et contrôler ces compétitions
qui à mon avis sont importantes ou
parfois il peuTent se passer même
parfois du trafic de de de produits
d'upan alors après c'était concernant le
euh le le le la lutte de manière globale
je crois que ce qui est très très
important ce dont parlait ran là
justement c'est l'indépendance de de de
la sanction moi comme par hasard c'est
vraiment du pur hasard c'est que
j'arrive je suis entendu auès
aujourd'hui auprès de la commission
d'enquête et il semblerait quand même
que je j'ai enfin réussi au bout de 8
mois à être relaxé d'une sanction qui
m'avait été attribuée par une la
Fédération Française de Cyclisme
pourquoi pour ne pas mettre sous un
contrôle donc je n'avais pas la
connaissance c'est quand même ahurissant
j'ai pris 14 mois à la première instance
14 mois qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
derrière vous prenez un avocat et vous
devez vous défendre pendant 8 mois mais
bien sûr première fois vous défendez
auprès de qui auprès de la Fédération
c'est ça devient un peu compliqué donc
vous prenez un mois on vous dit que vous
êtes innocent on vous met un mois et au
final vous passez enfin devant une
instance indépendante et il semblerait
du moins je l'espère ça devrait tomber
bientôt et comme je fais totale
confiance à la FLD du moins grâce à son
indépendance et la compétence des gens
qui sont à l'intérieur du coup je vais
être relaxé prochainement donc je crois
qu'il y a réellement un problème
là-dessus vous en avez parlé tout à
l'heure il est évident que
l'indépendance est nécessaire sur le
plan
disciplinaire merci Grégory Michel et
ensuite ou Jean la fonan comme vous le
souhaitez le premier qui prend le micro
parle sur la fon oui c'est une réflexion
qui m'est venue C à l'intervention de
Monsieur Michel et de Christophe basson
euh la la difficulté je crois à ce
niveau-là c'est les choix de devant
lesquels on met les compétiteurs de ce
niveau et finalement quel type de
solution on leur offre
et je crois que ça c'est le problème
social je suis moi en tant qu'éducateur
je suis très très critique à l'égard du
sport tel qu'il se développe aujourd'hui
je crois que il y a une vision de la
compétition qui se fait au détriment de
l'individu c'est une compétition féroce
et je crois que le sport ne représente
plus on pourrait dire un développement
multilatéral de l'individu on
hypertrophie un certain nombre de ses
capacités au détriment de l'autre et on
forme des citoyens désorientés je crois
que le souci qu'on doit avoir c'est de
raisonner par rapport à la constitution
du citoyen que l'on veut que l'on veut
inventer alors je comprends bien ce que
dit Christophe basson moi je ne suis pas
un désespéré de la lutte sinon on n'est
pas enseignant je un je de métier je
crois qu'on est dans une société aussi
où le sport CR des héros je le
sous-estime pas je suis moi pour que on
ne laisse pas le sport d' ha niveau
voger seul ça galère un jour ça nous
reviendra sur les bras d'ailleurs ça se
passe toujours comme ça quand il y a
difficultés on se retourne ensuite vers
le le bien public donc moi je suis pour
encadrer tout le monde je crois que le
travail doit être mené systématiquement
je pense mais je dis dès l'école vous
saz il faut changer de d'école je c'est
pas des rythmes scolaires qu'il faut
inventer c'est d'autres contenus
d'enseignement que qui enrichit
la part de la formation citoyenne et
nous n'en sommes pas là les débats que
nous avons aujourd'hui nous n'en sommes
pas là on peut tous le regretter et je
dis le sport crée des héros alors que la
société les héros qu'il nous offre bien
souvent ne sont pas à hauteur d'une
vision républicaine des choses donc
voilà ces choix-l et bien les individus
les affrontent avec leurs faiblesses et
je crois que le rôle de l'éducateur mais
surtout de la loi parce que la loi dans
ces CASL libère c'est de cadrer les
comportements les plus justes et
conformes à l'aspiration
républicaine merci Grigory Michel
oui pour aller dans dans le prolongement
de sa réflexion de répondre un petit peu
à à certaines à certains commentaires
moi non plus je suis pas un désespéré
effectivement de de la prévention je je
moi je crois beaucoup à une prévention
mais une prévention comme comme je l'ai
rappelé c'est une prévention large une
prévention précoce aussi sans sans
justement s'inscrire dans ce risque qui
a été
aussi mentionné dans des programmes de
prévention précoce celui un peu de voilà
de stigmatiser avec avec ce cette espèce
de de flou entre prévention et
prédiction c'est au contraire de de
donner la possibilité à des à des jeunes
qui n'ont pas justement cette chance
d'avoir un milieu familial soutenant
étayant à l'écoute aussi des
spécificités de leur enfant pour des
raisons très diversifiées c'est-à-dire
un manque de disponibilité affective des
problèmes aussi socio et cetera moi je
crois beaucoup à ça alors je crois c'est
pas simplement que de l'ORD de la
croyance c'est qu'il a un certain n de
de travaux qui montre aussi leur
efficacité mais leur efficacité à partir
du moment où c'est quelque chose
d'écologique donc c'est vrai que j'ai
pas mentionné peut-être la participation
je sais que c'est compliqué des parents
mais c'est tenir compte de
l'environnement c'est tenir compte
l'environnement de l'enfant dans son
dans sa globalité donc c'est des
programmes qui sont effectivement un peu
lourds mais c'est des programmes qui ont
une réelle efficacité
et qui en plus dans le temps savère être
finalement sur le plan coûp bénéfice
assez intéressant quoi mais ça s'inscrit
dans une réflexion beaucoup plus large
effectivement de la société c'est que ce
que disait Christophe basson ce paradoxe
on est dans le culte de la performance
on est justement avec aussi lesf les
nouvelles technologies les jeunes ce
sont des digital natives ils sont nés
avec donc bon mais mais c'est ça c'est
vivre en faisant des choses
spectaculaires c'est se dépasser être
différent effectivement de des autres et
puis en même temps on va effectivement
dans une logique qui sera celle
justement de pas donner les moyens de
faire quelque chose de spectaculaire
donc il y a un réel paradoxe où on est
dans une société où on va privilégier
finalement le faire faire quelque chose
d'extraordinaire l'avoir aussi on
parlait de l'apparence corporelle des
vêtements et cetera mais en revanche
cette société finalement de l'être ou
donc ce qu'on disait c'estàd l'estime de
soi les valeurs finalement qui sont de
l'ORD d'un épanouissement personnel
c'est des valeurs finalement qui
reviennent maintenant par certains
collègues psychiatres psychologues
sociologues et cetera mais ça reste
encore très embryonnaire à la fois sur
le plan de la réflexion et surtout sur
le plan très pragmatique donc je pense
que les les interventions sont
importantes mais à partir du moment où
aussi on ne se limite pas au domaine
purement effectivement sportif parce que
c'est beaucoup plus large parce que il y
a une une question effectivement qui se
pose et je pense qu'on on en est tous
très conscient et le dopage je trouve le
souigne très bien c'est la notion aussi
de de personnalité qui est circonscrite
uniquement à la performance qui est
uniquement à une activité c'est qu'on
est dans un un mode finalement de
d'identité qui est simplement limité à
une seule identité une seule performance
donc après ça pose la question de voilà
l'adaptation à la société l'adaptation à
d'autres à d'autres rôles et à d'autres
fonctionn et ça s'apprend
ouais en fait moi je vis vous poser une
question je suis je
d'accord alors je suis moi aussi
convaincu par l'idée que créer un
écosystème autour d'un enfant pour qu'il
aille
mieux évidemment ça l'aiderait à aller
mieux mais c'est une affaire de moyen
c'est utopique de croire qu'on va
pouvoir aller faire de la de la
prévention et de créer tout un
écosystème en impliquant les parents en
mettant tout pendant des années pour
qu'il arrive à devenir un mec équilibré
sain et qui va pas aller au dopage moi
je j'en rêve de ça évidemment j'aimerais
cette proposition de société pour
n'importe quel enfant qu'on puisse
l'aider à être équilibré et être un bon
citoyen maintenant pour moi c'est
illusoire puisque vous voyez bien
comment à quoi on en est rendu
aujourd'hui le budget de l'État et
cetera je vois pas comment on va trouver
des moyens pour ça en revanche il y a un
truc si on met des
règles
strict la même dans tous les sports on
va va avoir une vision en se disant
voilà si on fait ça on se fait choper à
chaque fois et là on aura pas la même
envie de le faire parce que si on on
valorise un mec par exemple comme l
Armstrong et récemment j'ai entendu des
trucs qui m'ont hérissé et qui sont en
plein dans le problème qu'on est en
train de toucher on est en train de dire
oui mais Armstrong c'est quand même un
mec il a quand même gagné quand même
gagné 7 tours de France c'est quand même
un championah qu'est-ce que vous dites à
un enfant c'est ça le problème pour moi
c'est ça le problème c'est là
l'éducation c'est qu'est-ce qu'on va
dire à nos enfants quand on regarde les
champions qui
trichent
oui justement pour pour pour appuyer
encore sur ce que dit Erwan c'est que
pire encore quel est l'image pour un
enfant l'image d'enfant c'est quoi c'est
qui réussit en fait en fait c'est clair
le résumé il est rapide c'est que celui
qui a utilisé des produits d'opan il a
gagné de belles courses il a gagné
beaucoup d'argent il est devenu
quelqu'un et mieux encore c'est la
personne que l'on reconvertit derrière à
qui on offre une reconversion parce que
qui c'est que vous trouvez à la tête de
toutes les équipes professionnelles qui
c'est que vous trouvez comme consultant
télévisé qui c'est que vous trouvez à la
tête de parfois des équipes de France ce
sont des gens qui probablement on est
fort soupçon et même parfois convaincus
qu'ils ont été dopés donc je crois que
là-dessus il y a réellement un problème
d'image mais il y a un deuxième point
que je souhaitais aborder c'est le côté
du médical quelle doit être la place du
médical dans le sport au final parce
qu'on se souvient bien que le médical
est arrivé quand même pour améliorer la
performance au début dans les années
j'ai pas trop d'histoire moi en terme de
cyclisme mais moi personnellement j'ai
fait 6 années de professionnel cycliste
j'ai jamais fait appel à mon médecin
d'équipe j'en avais pas besoin vous êtes
sur les courses vous avez le médecin de
courses vous êtes chez vous vous avez
médecin médecin traitant alors pourquoi
on vous met dans médecin dans une équipe
c'est pour vous aider à récupérer c'est
pour vous améliorer vos performances
c'est tout et à partir de momentl alors
c'est vrai si vous avez un jeune qui
arrive avec faible psychologiquement
c'est-à-dire une une estime de soi qui
lu permet pas peut-être de de de
s'opposer à certains faits en plus vous
le formez à lui dire on peut t'aider à
récupérer par le médical et c'est comme
ça que maintenant on se retrouve comment
on se retrouve que dans le rugby vous
allez dans les centres de formation et
la prise de compléments alimentaire est
organisée par le Centre de Formation
est-ce que c'est réellement normal
pourquoi parce qu'on a peur que les
jeunes prennent des compléments
alimentaires entre guillemets sal qui
contiennent les substance dopante c'est
exactement comme a fait Bruno Roussel
avant laffire festinant c'est pour
éviter que certains coureurs prennent
des produits dont il n'avait pas la
connaissance il a souhaité organiser le
dopage en l'qu festinant on trouve la
même chose au niveau des compléments
alimentaires maintenant et c'est
réellement une ure de la conduite
d'pante comme pouvez le dire le prof
docteur monsieur la tout à l'heure donc
c'est ça je crois que il y a réellement
problème il y a le début c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal à maîtriser comme disait
ran au niveau de l'éducation on peut
quand même intervenir j'y crois quand
même je le fais j'intervient auprès des
jeunes et je crois que c'est même c'est
pas auprès des jeunes qu' faut
intervenir c'est auprès de l'entourage
des jeunes pour qu'il a un discours
commun auprès de ces jeunes voilà pour
cette table ronde de la commission
d'enquête sénatoriale sur le dopage si
vous souhaitez la revoir ou en savoir
plus sur les travaux de la commission
d'enquête notre site internet
publsenat.fr bonne journée à
[Musique]
tous